I feel like you were the Halloween Queen
yeah I love the memories that I create
with my friends around Halloween time
they're my favorite memories you just
robbed sleeping kissing dance are you
kind of taking some time now to yourself
no time no time to sleep honestly I
my sister reminded me of something when
I was in the car earlier that I need it
and I was like time for me to read The
Four Agreements again I feel like it's
such a great book it's so centering and
just kind of like keeps you your head on
straight yeah yeah I was obsessed with
your song with Sean hook more plans for
more music I mean it's all right it
takes a lot of time and like I only want
to make music that I want to listen to
or so feel like it's a really specific
thing and I feel like when the time's
right when all of my introductions are
aligned it'll happen I'm in no rush well
this new moon with you Nina Dobrev you
guys start shooting this fall so what
attracted you to this project not much
is known about it Monday going Monday
it's kind of like a Love Actually story
where everyone's story interconnect it's
a whole bunch of different storylines
but it's about the hook I feel like the
world's so crazy and hectic right now we
all need something to bring us together
I love it and it's awesome here with you
tonight yeah yeah how do you guys
balance the long distance I feel like
he's always working you're always
working on FaceTime I tell everyone
FaceTime
[Music]
you
[Music]